have you weighed yourself because your
face looks thinner to me i have weighed
my weight myself this morning
and i'm down nine and a half pounds from
uh from where i started so yeah so
all in the face apparently what's your
goal weight
i mean i want to lose 100 pounds that's
what i set out to do so i want to get
down to 200 i started at 300
uh 0.5 and i want to get down to 200. so
i want to see
you you sexy bastard in a speedo this
summer
at 200 pounds yes very much so
i'd like
jason used to uh work in a fast food
restaurant when he was a kid and i was
like which one did you work in by the
way rogers
yeah and you were saying you were like
employee of the month all the time
because you just showed up on time
yeah but i was asking if you could you
know eat all the food you want while
you're working there
the key to the food at roy rogers and
i'm assuming any fast food place was
waiting right before closing
um and then putting down i put down like
a whole thing of chicken
fried chicken is so good there and uh
and hamburgers and all my favorite foods
i'd make them and then
the store would close and then you have
to throw out all the food that has been
made and hasn't been sold so
that would just go into a big bag come
back to my house we had a whole second
refrigerator my house set up for roy
rogers food it was
a second refrigerator oh yeah and i
could walk in like a middle of the night
i could walk down and get like a bacon
double cheeseburger
wrapped up in the roy rogers rapping oh
it was amazing he was getting a nice
little uh
little stash i was feeding phenomenally
yeah
i had two brothers and two parents and
no we had the second refrigerator just
ended up getting uh overtaken by
roy rogers food did anyone catch on that
you were doing this and complain or
they didn't care howard i was doing the
least creepiest thing in the roy rogers
i mean please i
i was you know taking fried chicken home
on a friday night
uh uh was almost the same as showing up
on time i wasn't sexually harassing
anybody i wasn't threatening customers
you got sexually harassed when you were
there what happened yeah yeah well first
of all it's very skinny uh back then uh
this was before the downfall
um at one time robin
it uh
and what happened who sexually harassed
you this guy is this guy who was you
know friendly at work
i thought it was a woman it's like oh no
that would have been a date i was in
high school you kidding me right
yeah it was this weird thing and all of
a sudden i was getting ice and he like
cornered me so i couldn't get out and he
kept saying how nice i looked in my
outfit i was like oh thank you and he
kept getting like closer and like kept
stepping closer and closer to me though
i realized i couldn't move i was like
pinned against the
shelf and i'm like what are you i'm like
what are you doing i'm like
get away from me i was like laughing and
he's like come on man come on you know
and he's like
leaning in and i had a sleeve of uh cups
in my hand you know they used to put the
cups in a big giant sleeve and i just it
started hitting them over the head with
it
and then i just went back to work you
were the brad pitt of roy rogers
i mean wow